sama royal signer au tabac est à mais
jamais vu mais bon en vrai raymond je
t'aime moi c'est important l'amour en
juin et on espère les autres mais on en
met deux panthères ça va alors céline je
sais que tu vas me relancer des concepts
qui avait disparu et je dis tu a invité
le docteur jimmy mohamed pour redonner
vie au jeu de notre enfance dessinez
c'est gagné
[Applaudissements]
un oeuf foot benzema maintenant c'est
les boucles d'oreilles d'isabelle
morini-bosc mais non mais c'est un
soleil dans le ciel on dirait abbas et
bernard montiel enfin bronze à l'épée
n'zima arrête tes chiens ans comprend
rien ce qui lie cette station spatiale
le truc aux accents il a chain est ce là
abbas et steevy boulay quasiment à temps
il refait un autre truc la douma
j'abandonne
non mais vas-y on l'a par là bas ni
d'amour on savait pas c'était alors un
message est pas facile la version
médicale de ce jeu cyril pas de perte de
temps pour débriefer le reste de la
semaine de tpm p hier soir lille a été
champion ouais bravo aux lillois relais
bravo lille moira les nouvelles dans un
instant partons tout de suite rejoindre
stéphane est fini pour le multi des
complexes soient toutes deux sont tous
bienvenue au multi des complexes et
encore une fois cette semaine philippe
sella police et les moments les plus
décomplexée oui bonsoir stéphane et bien
effectivement avec des invités en roue
libre des chroniqueurs qui se lâche bref
du lourd dans tous les sens du terme
[Musique]
dans comment déjà été meilleur buteur du
championnat qui vient même pas si
mauvais que ça n'est pas du psg monaco
magnifique habite du non respect oui
mais en plein du bassin et y aller ya
match beauvais ce joueur je le trouve un
sensationnel
il est magnifique il a jamais fait ça
pour rambo par exemple à caillavet rambo
car android il a des colonels c'était
pas ma guerre d'accord c'est vous qui
m'avez rappelait pas moi moi j'étais là
j'étais la jeune stop stop ou parce
qu'on est dans la guerre et le guerrier
de la semaine c'est lui c'est son coeur
et a laissé son coeur est en algérie
moi je l'invite à être cohérents et à
jouer pour l'équipe nationale algérienne
s'est fait ravir lotis les footballeurs
il en affaires djihadistes comme ça là
mais quel talent il trouve disant bull
même quand il y en a pas exactement mais
vous savez ce qu'on dit dans la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
c'est l'empereur qui avait dix à qui ça
à napoléon nord guy roux au petit but en
contre attaque du point soleil bernard
montiel
je voulais simplement dire vive
l'algerie cuisine l'algérie ne se défend
tout au moins que ça soit le crime et la
vive l'algérie vive l'algérie au mondial
algérien du cap ferret sa vie prend là
bas ils enclenchent la couche de
personnes se sentant le franc bien
enroulé oui il pète à 10 le front
national c'est sûr il aura son champ à
la prochaine coupe d'afrique des nations
two three viva bernardi elle est bonne
elle est valeur sait pas on me signale
deux joueurs qui ont craqué durant
jubilé de temps intérieur
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouais ce cancer se faire vacciner
[Applaudissements]
face à isabelle à ça pas maintenant pas
après tout ce que tu as fait c'est
dommage elle est très aidée henry de tpm
pella morini bosc et verdez quel dommage
y sont alors 12 emilien titularisation
il craque à ce moment là ça me fait du
mal de quitter les gens image vaut n'a
pas le choix n'oubliez pas beaucoup
tracas beaucoup de blabla chez mena
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]